maintenant j'ai entendu dire
qu'il y avait une corde secrète que David
jouait
et cela plaisait au seigneur mais vous ne vous
souciez pas vraiment de la musique est-
ce que
ça se passe comme ça le quatrième
le cinquième le mineur tombe
le majeur soulève le
roi déconcerté composant alléluia
[Musique  ]
oh
j'ai fait de mon mieux ce n'était pas grand-chose
je ne pouvais pas le sentir alors j'avais essayé de
toucher
j'ai dit la vérité je ne suis pas venu
[Musique]
avec rien sur ma langue
mais alléluia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi,
salut
[Musique]
ce gars a probablement combattu des centaines de
milliers d'autres super êtres sur les
autres planètes qu'il a détruites et
nous devons supposer qu'il a gagné, je me fiche du
nombre de démons qu'il a combattus et du nombre d'
enfers
qu'il n'a jamais combattus nous pas nous  vous unis